[Music]
on this thursday night
the warning bells about outbreaks in
schools
just days into a new term students in
alberta sent home
after cases are found in high schools
watching these outbreaks happen in the
first week of school is definitely
concerning
quebec unmasks its new penalties for
people refusing to follow
kovid19 rules also tonight
is there more to we charity shutting
shop in canada
this was a group that was desperately
looking for some form of bailout because
of kovac
they just happen to know all the key
ministers they happen to have all their
numbers
and the destruction along america's west
coast
the eerie skies as wildfires rage
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
it's the news parents and health
officials feared as more
students returned to class today were
learning about more cases of covet 19
at schools in alberta the province is
reporting outbreaks at three schools and
at least
21 schools in the province have each
reported one positive case of covid19
alberta's top doctor says no one should
be surprised that a few cases have been
linked to schools
given the numbers in the province have
been climbing in recent days
in manitoba a student at a winnipeg high
school has tested positive
in bc a province which saw a record
spike today
thousands of students returned to class
the reopening pandemic plan involves
different
entry and exit points on school grounds
as well as varying lunch
and recess times this is the new
new uh new normal for all of us so
it is we're going to do our
responsibility as parents as well
they've adapted better than some of the
adults i think
you know the the kids understand what
what's going on they understand social
distancing
every parent has that kin first aid
kindergarten pit in their stomach
i'm still not sure i made the right
decision for countless parents the
decision whether or not to send their
children back to class has weighed
heavily on their minds for months
and as jamie dahl reports the news about
covet 19 cases in alberta schools
is only adding to that uneasiness
the student body has only been back at
this calgary high school since
tuesday and already a coveted 19
outbreak has been declared
it's stressful and it's really
you know it's scary to see because some
people you know especially
like right now at lunch people don't
keep their distance without masks and
whatnot that's
really really nerve-wracking an outbreak
means there are two or more cases in a
school
as of thursday afternoon at least three
outbreaks have been confirmed
two in calgary and one in lethbridge
some students say it's almost impossible
to physically distance what would have
been a class of 35 is now 40
or 43 which is intense especially when
you have to try to spread out in the
rooms that don't get bigger
sixteen schools in the province have
reported one positive case of covid 19
where the infected person was in the
building hundreds were sent home
we are acting out of an abundance of
caution by treating two cases
who were in a school while infectious
within a 14-day span
as an outbreak even when the cases are
within
one family this is an extremely
low threshold to meet the province of
alberta launched an online map so
parents and students can see which
schools
have had two or more cases none of the
infected people got the virus from a
school setting
but right now that is the biggest fear
individual cases appearing at a school
especially if they're
caught or contracted in the community
not at all surprising
the key is to ensure that we don't lead
to large spreading events within the
school
contact tracing is being done and anyone
considered to be in close contact with
positive cases
is being asked to self-isolate alberta
health services will not say if its
students or staff infected
but this parent who is also a student
advocate says the government school
mitigation plan
falls short they have to recognize that
classrooms are crowded that physical
distancing
is a key strategy to mitigating the
spread of covid
and they have to fix the infrastructure
of our system
to accommodate for this change cases
have risen back up to numbers not
seen in the province since may only
fueling the anxiety of parents
as some now rethink the risk of sending
their kids
back to school jamie doll global news
calgary
and alberta saw a large surge in cases
today 113 more people
tested positive in that province bc
reported 139 new cases today
a new daily record there were six in
saskatchewan
15 in manitoba in new brunswick there
was one new infection
ontario has 170 new cases while quebec
has the most confirmed cases again today
with 188. and quebec is cracking down on
people who don't wear masks
back in july that province was the first
to mandate masks in
indoor public places now it's the first
to hand out fines for people caught not
respecting that mandate
mike armstrong explains quebec's premier
admits
most are following the mask mandate it's
just a small minority
that's left him frustrated unfortunately
in a society
you always have few people that are
irresponsible
cases like this one back in july have
been few and far between
accustomed to tim horton's refusing to
wear a mask and then refusing to leave
he was arrested by police
starting saturday quebec is giving
police officers
another tool the ability to ticket
people not wearing masks
inside in public spaces how big the
finds will be is still being worked out
that announcement will come friday from
the justice minister
i think it's a terrific idea harry sheik
has been hoping the government would
take a tougher stance
after his bakery was shut down for three
and a half months he's had enough to
worry about just staying in business
he hasn't enjoyed having to argue with
customers about masks
we're not enforcement we're just trying
to get along and trying to make a living
now there will be pushback from some
there have been several anti-mask
protests
the premier says more can take place if
they're outside protesters won't be
ticketed
but he is having trouble understanding
the cause they're fighting for
some of these people they even think
that
elvis is alive all we're trying to do is
protect all the communities
that's it the ontario premier is talking
fines as well doug ford says too many
people are breaking the federal
quarantine act and not
facing consequences since late march
anyone returning to canada is supposed
to self-isolate for 14 days the only
exception is essential workers
ford says in ontario police have found
more than 600 people
breaking quarantine but federal
authorities have only charged
17. they should get a fine you can't
just say slap on the wrist
okay guys don't worry about it because
if you do it again we'll slap you on the
wrist again
it doesn't make sense there is another
announcement coming from quebec
karaoke bars started receiving notices
thursday they're being ordered to shut
down
this comes after one night of singing in
a bar last month
was found to be responsible for more
than 80 cases
of the coronavirus mike armstrong global
news montreal
now to the fallout from we charities
shutting down its canadian operations
investigations are underway into the
controversy surrounding the
organization's
failed student grant program but there
are major questions about how those
probes can carry on and exactly
how we plans to restructure abigail
beeman
is digging into that story we will be
closing wheat charities operations in
canada
in announcing the end in canada we
charity offered big numbers
youth who logged over 70 million
volunteer hours 30
000 small businesses run by women
lifting their families out of poverty
but there is still
uncertainty from the charity the
government claims was the only one
capable of carrying out the canada
student service grant program
over the next 6 to 12 months the
founding kielbergers will sell off
assets
including the toronto headquarters to
fund an endowment to keep international
projects going
and put all resources online but they
have a lot of other
entities in a statement to global news
we charity says
the american arm is not currently
impacted and the future of the
for-profit social enterprise me to we
still hasn't been determined
this was a group that was desperately
looking for some form of bailout because
of covid
and they just happened to know all the
key ministers
that's the question i'm focused on the
opposition is pushing its investigation
at parliamentary committees
paused by parliament's prorogation this
isn't about a witch hunt this isn't
about political gamesmanship this is
about
reassuring canadians that money that is
spent in a pandemic and we are going to
spend enormous amounts of money to get
people through this crisis that that
money is being spent
for the best interests of the canadian
people full stop
there's a lot of questions that still
need to be answered
and just like pro-roguing parliament
doesn't shut down this investigation
uh closing up their canadian shop
doesn't uh
relieve the reorganization of their
obligations to provide information
to parliament are there lessons to be
learned from that episode sure
but decisions by we are solely decisions
by we and i think we're going to
continue doing what we have always said
we were going to do which is support
canadians through this
late this afternoon we told global news
it would be happy to turn over those
documents
once there's a new committee we also
know the ethics commissioner is
investigating the prime minister and
former finance minister bill morneau but
no word yet from justin trudeau on the
organization's decision to close
in canada abigail beeman global news
ottawa and today another black mark for
bill morneau
canada's election watchdog says he broke
the rules during the 2019
election on the campaign trail morneau
promoted two liberal candidates in his
official capacity as a cabinet minister
the election commissioner says that
amounts to using public office for
partisan gain
it violates a section of the election
act that prohibits anyone but
individuals from donating to political
parties
essentially the government which paid
for the events is not an individual
mourinho has agreed to pay a 300 fine
and post a link to the ruling on his
website
and social media accounts in british
columbia a highly anticipated decision
has been reached in a long-running legal
battle over the role of private care
in canada's health care system bc's
supreme court has ruled against a
vancouver surgeon who argued that
patients should have the right to pay
for private care
if they're left waiting too long for
public care dr
brian day who opened the camby surgery
center
launched the challenge arguing bc's
medicare protection act puts limits on
private care
and violates the charter of rights and
freedoms today after a three-year trial
involving more than 100 witnesses
the court ruled the limits do not
contravene the charter
turning now to the united states where
the devastation is growing from
wildfires raging
up and down the west coast in california
oregon and washington state
crews are struggling to contain dozens
of fires the fierce winds aren't helping
so far at least 15 people have died
including a toddler
and thousands of homes have been
destroyed eric sorenson reports on the
growing toll from this destructive fire
season
and the efforts to get the situation
under control
there have been extraordinary escapes as
swirling fires cut off routes to safety
there was fire 360 degrees around me
rescuers have done heroic work limiting
the human toll
plucking campers trapped in the burning
forest it was just this huge billowing
cloud it was like a nuclear bomb
exploding but the destruction and misery
is widespread and growing
in phoenix oregon the entire town wiped
out
this senior's home reduced to ashes the
center has burned with all of our things
everything i own is there and the
wildfires are moving quickly
this will not be a one-time event
unfortunately
it is the bellwether of the future
satellite images show
smoke spreading over much of the pacific
coast in san francisco
street lights on at midday the look of
the sky
apocalyptic it feels like the end of the
world what's remarkable
is the breadth of the fires burning up
and down the u.s west coast
in washington state more than 130
thousand hectares burned in one day
that's more than all of last year in
oregon a state that is normally damp and
cool
three major fires are burning and a
small town destroyed
and in california several major fires
are ablaze
some near san francisco overall more
than a million hectares have burned
and there are still several weeks to go
in this fire season
a record heat wave set the stage for the
wildfires
even the weather maps look ablaze
another 100 record highs are possible
drought and warm air dried the brush and
trees
perfect fuel for wildfires they're
higher intensity fires which are
difficult to impossible to extinguish
california has seen a quadrupling
of area burns since the 70s and this is
largely due to climate change seeing
devastation almost every year now
western governors are not among the
climate deniers
this is an extraordinary series of
events we have suffered
they are the result of catastrophically
climatic systems climate advocates say
all governments must look at what's
happening with wildfires
and act the longer governments take to
respond the more unpredictable things
are going to be
and the more destruction i think we can
anticipate having to manage in our daily
lives
this fire season has received less
attention amid a pandemic and a
cratering economy
but 2020s wildfires are say scientists
historic
and there will be more of them in the
future eric sorensen global news
a huge fire has broken out at beirut's
port rattling nerves after last month's
catastrophic blast
the military says it was sparked when
cooking oil caught fire and spread to a
tire warehouse
crews are battling the blaze from the
air and on the ground but there are no
concerns of an explosion
and no injuries have been reported on
august 4 more than 2 700 tons of
ammonium nitrate exploded
killing nearly 200 people and injuring
more than 6 000 others
a widespread cleanup is still underway
in greece help is on the way for
thousands of migrants left without
shelter after a fire destroyed their
camp
today aid was handed out to the many who
have lost everything
about 13 000 people had been living in
squalor at the camp which was meant for
only 3 000 people
greece is sending three ships to the
island to provide shelter for
some as well as emergency tents germany
and france say they'll take in about 400
miners
whose parents aren't with them
the white house in damage control coming
up the damning revelations that
president trump purposely tried to
mislead the american people
about the pandemic
the white house is in damage control
mode tonight over revelations the
president
deliberately misled americans about the
seriousness of kova 19.
donald trump insists he downplayed the
threat to protect the public
but as jackson proskow explains his
actions are just one part of the failure
by the u.s
to effectively fight the pandemic why
did you
lie to the american people and why
should we trust what you have to say
terrible question and the phraseology i
didn't lie
as president donald trump tries to
manage a crisis of his own creation
he's left on the defensive over his
failure to share key information about
the severity of covet 19.
i don't want to jump up and down and
start screaming death
death because that's not what it's about
trump now claims he did the american
people a favor by downplaying the threat
even as he acknowledged to journalist
bob woodward that the virus was far
worse than the flu
this is more deadly this is five per
you know this is five percent versus one
percent and less than one percent
you know so this is deadly stuff if
americans had been told that initially
dr peter hotez believes they would have
taken the pandemic
far more seriously there's a consequence
the american public never
really fully understood or appreciated
the gravity of
the coven 19 epidemic until they started
seeing
family members and friends get sick or
hospitalized
today more than 190 000 americans are
dead
the u.s economy is struggling and
there's still a debate
fueled by trump about preventative
measures like face masks and
restrictions on gatherings
that could save even more lives it had
the effect of turning this into what was
one of the worst
public health disasters in modern
american history
into something even bigger which is a
homeland security threat
the question is whether voters will care
michigan's governor gave a preview of
the argument democrats are likely to
make
they knew they didn't tell us trump
isn't taking the bait insisting he's
better suited than
anyone to lead during this once in a
generation crisis
expert or not we're not doing any more
shutdowns
trump is holding firm even as his
country records more cases and more
deaths
than any other nation on earth jackson
proskow global news
washington still ahead from stylish spy
to queen of thorns the career of the
late diana rigg
the entertainment world is mourning a
legend british actress dame diana rigg
has died by the way are you busy just
now
not today i've just written an article
for the science
weekly but that's finished in the 1960s
she played the elegant secret agent
emma peel on the avengers he loves me
instinctively insurance
intensely rigg then went on to play a
secret agent's wife in the james bond
film
on her majesty's secret service in that
role she was the only bond girl double
07 ever married
in 1994 the queen made her a dame
commander
the equivalent of sir for her service to
the arts
for today's audience she may be better
known as another dame
there are always lessons and failures
yes
you must be very wise by now
brig appeared in 18 episodes of game of
thrones as the scathing matriarch
lady olenna tyrell she stars in a period
drama series slated to come out later
this year
and a thriller set for 2021. her
daughter says she was battling cancer
for the past six months
diana rigg was 82 years old
the music world is mourning the talent
behind this dance favorite
celebration was one of the signature
songs from cool in the gang
ronald bell the singer songwriter and
saxophone player at the heart of this
funky music
has died when belle and his brother
robert cool were growing up in ohio
they couldn't afford drums so they
collected paint cans and taught
themselves percussion by how much paint
was left in each one
his other hit jungle boogie was part of
a musical career that lasted more than
50 years
ronald bell was 68.
up next raptors fans take over jurassic
park and
for good reason
the pandemic has made for a very
different playoff experience this year
all games are happening in the nba
bubble fans are not allowed to attend
but people are still finding ways to
celebrate safely
horns were honking last night at the
drive-in version of the jurassic park
fan zone in toronto you can bet the lot
will be filled again tomorrow night when
the raptors take on the celtics in a
must win
game seven the winner goes on to the
eastern conference final
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is lake cowhich in
bc we would love to see your corner of
this country
so send your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Applause]
[Music]
you